The completion of the Human Genome Project
lays a foundation for systematically studying
the human genome from evolutionary history
to precision medicine against diseases.
With the explosive growth of biological data,
there is an increasing number of biological
databases that have been developed in aid
of human-related research.
In this lecture, we will present a brief overview
of the major human related biological databases.
How the data is being arranged and classified
into different categories according to their
data types?
And, how to retrieve and analyze them?
As human-related databases continue to grow
not only in count but also in volume, challenges
are ahead in big data storage, processing,
exchange and curation.
What is a database?
A database is a collection of information
that is organized so that it can be easily
accessed, managed and updated.
Databases are composed of computer hardware
and software for data management.
The chief objective of the development of
a database is to organize data in a set of
structured records to enable easy retrieval
of information.
Although data retrieval is the main purpose
of all databases, biological databases often
have a higher level of requirement, known
as knowledge discovery, which refers to the
identification of connections between pieces
of information that were not known when the
information was first entered.
For example, databases containing raw sequence
information can perform extra computational
tasks to identify sequence homology or conserved
motifs.
These features facilitate the discovery of
new biological insights from raw data.
According to a report of 2014 Molecular Biology
Database Collection in the journal Nucleic
Acids Research, there are a sum of 1552 databases
that are publicly accessible online.
This does not include online services without
publication in peer-reviewed journal or being
developed by commercial companies.
Thus, the actual number of online databases
could well exceed this number.
Considering the continuously proliferating
number of biological databases, it becomes
increasingly daunting and time-consuming to
navigate in the huge volume of databases of
interest.
Considering the heterogeneity in data type,
scope and curation, biological databases can
be classified into multiple categories under
different criteria.
According to the scope of data coverage, biological
databases can be classified as comprehensive
and specialized databases.
Comprehensive databases cover different types
of data from numerous species and typical
examples are GenBank, European Molecular Biology
Laboratory (EMBL), and DNA Data Bank of Japan
(DDBJ).
These three databases were established as
the International Nucleotide Sequence Database
Collaboration in 1988 to collect and disseminate
DNA and RNA sequences.
On the other hand, specialized databases contain
specific types of data or data from specific
organisms.
For example, WormBase is for nematode biology
and genomics, and RiceWiki is for community
curation of rice genes.
According to the level of data curation, biological
databases can roughly fall into primary and
secondary or derivative databases.
Primary databases contain raw data as archival
repository such as the NCBI Sequence Read
Archive (SRA), whereas secondary or derivative
databases contain curated information as added
value, e.g., NCBI RefSeq.
As a consequence of the explosive growth of
data, curation increasingly requires collective
intelligence for collaborative data integration
and annotation.
Therefore, biological databases can also be
classified as expert-curated databases, e.g.,
RefSeq and TAIR, and community-curated databases,
which are curated in a collective and collaborative
manner by a number of researchers, e.g., LncRNAWiki
and GeneWiki.
Finally, according to the types of data managed
in different databases, biological databases
can roughly fall into the following categories:
DNA, RNA, protein, expression, pathway, disease,
nomenclature, literature, and standard and
ontology.
Despite having highly different functions,
almost all biological databases shared similar
architectual.
Each consists of three tiers of software.
At the bottom is a database management system
(DBMS) that manages a collection of facts.
At the top is the web browser that transmits
requests for data to the database and renders
the responses as web pages.
In the middle is a software layer that mediates
between the DBMS and the web browser to turn
data requests into database queries, and to
transform the query responses into hypertext
mark-up language (HTML).
In addition to the Gene Database and PDB,
there are many more biological databases designed
for different purposes.
The table here shows some of the most commonly
used databases in bioinformatics that might
help you in your research.